I never studied Shakespeare at
University I never took a college course
on Shakespeare uh I was bumming around
Europe a lot in my late teens and found
myself in London and started going to
the theater RSC National Royal Court
hitchhiking up to the Edinburgh festival
and I started seeing Shakespeare plays
all the time and I hold down some job
and come over to England to see 20 plays
in 20 days year after year and it was
like a drug and it was also better than
any drug I was taking at the time and uh
I've continued to uh take that drug for
many years and uh I'm very lucky to
spend my life immersed in Shakespeare so
that's how I came to Shakespeare and uh
kind of like is it Demetrius alander one
of those lovers in Midsummer stays
drugged and in love that's the way I
have experienc exper very good thank you
and nitel a little bit about your
milonic Beginnings I have it's very
interesting I have a sort of Converse
experience so I I grew up in North
London or on the edge of uh London and
South hartfordshire and you you got a
lot of Shakespeare at at school then and
uh so this would be in the 1970s
and I remember when I was 11 so that was
in 1970 being taken to see a local
School production of A Midsummer Night
stream and I was quite Amazed by the
acting even though of course it was
Secondary School acting so in fact it
probably wasn't very good at all um and
I was amazed by the way in which the
Shakespeare's interest in imagination in
illusion how how how love needs both to
work um was realized in in a performance
and then as I went through um as I went
through the rest of secondary school and
then on to University um so it's very
hard in this country to escape from the
hold of Shakespeare and indeed if you
live in the London area to escape from
the the presence of old plays of
Renaissance Theater being performed in
in ales um of which we're very proud in
this country so um although it wasn't um
well I I I do remember seeing um an
amazing performance of of Hamlet at The
Roundhouse um I remember seeing being
taken to Stratford to see Donald sinden
playing King leer and that was an
amazing evening that I'll never ever
forget and it made King Lea my favorite
play um so how did I get to Milton we
had two books of Paradise Lost to learn
for a level and actually I couldn't get
on terms with it
um in fact the whole class couldn't get
on terms with it and in the end I think
the teacher gave up and we we skipped it
you know it was it was it was more
rewarding it seemed to do Thomas Hardy
Harold Pinter and three Shakespeare
plays um but I went to University I
actually went to the University of Hull
in the northeast of England and the
reason I did that was to read um history
as well as English because I couldn't
decide which I wanted to do and you
could do that there and suppose it was
learning 17th century history in the
first year and also being taught
Milton and then I realized my God this
guy is so ambitious The Poetry is
written and realized according to this
fantastic plan where he's trying to
outdo everyone who's ever written poetry
before not just in English but in any
language as far as he could know it at
the time and it's a it's actually a
whole approach to living it's a it's a
philosophy um and he has these he has
these interesting values he he doesn't
he doesn't like monarchs um he's kind of
Against the Grain he's a rebel that was
interesting too so although it was far
too late in the N late 1970s to be
experimenting with substances um
certainly one one could have um strong
opinions about um public matters
political matters as one one certainly
did up in Hull at the time and and
Milton along with William Blake a great
um poetic totem um for such things so um
my story is really that as I I I didn't
really discover
myself until that first term at
University and then I realized I was
going to be a literature Professor
within about six weeks really it's all I
wanted it's all I've ever wanted to do
and I'm and I'm still doing it it's a
great privilege and and Milton has been
the the the great guide because he he
aimed at so much he achieved an awful
lot of it and he did it um uh
against with with the odds stacked
against him in a variety of ways which
we may come to talk about later on but
most of all um he is uh his vision he is
a Visionary poet and his vision is
astonishing in ways that I think this
evening might I hope surprise
you thank thank you very much I
think we will definitely come back to
quite a few of those points but now uh
we're going to get on with the meet of
our evening the two sections of advocacy
so we're going to begin uh with Jim
advocating for William Shakespeare thank
you take it
away I get a half an hour and I'm going
to share that with the actors who will
really make the case because they've
made the case for me I'm not here to
argue that Shakespeare is better than
Milton I'm really here to argue why I
value Shakespeare more than I value
Milton and I want to explain how I feel
and why I feel that way I should say
that as soon as Hannah set this up I
asked that I go second I've read Julius
Caesar and I know what happens when
Brutus goes
first but and then I argued
alphabetically it didn't work uh they
asked that I speak first I could stand
up here and argue with Harold Bloom that
Shakespeare invented the human I don't
believe that and I'm not here to gush in
those ways I could argue that
Shakespeare has contributed so much to
our language and his poetry is in many
ways unrivaled but neither of those
things
truly explain why I value Shakespeare as
much as I
do one of the most important an things
for me about Shakespeare and about a
life since my late teens steeped in
Shakespeare is that Shakespeare is the
great poet of
relationships I mean Fathers and Sons
fathers and daughters sisters and
sisters brothers servants and Masters
every relationship you can imagine
Shakespeare penetratingly explores and
relentlessly explores and in the sonnets
just one or two relationships are
penetratingly explored in 154 variations
that have been unrivaled but I had to
choose a scene to begin this evening
that captured for me the complexity of
how Shakespeare explores
relationships and Milton is pretty good
on
relationships but only for me up to a
point when I think of that great
miltonic line about Adam and Eve and I
don't want to get it wrong he for God
only she for God in him it serves as a
kind of dividing line between what
Shakespeare can offer and what Milton
does offer I made the lives of two of
our actors very difficult by asking them
to come in and do cold a scene from much
ad do about nothing and I'll introduce
that scene just to bring you up to speed
and explain a little bit about how this
captures what I'm talking about about
rendering the complexities of
relationships um why don't you stand up
so that I can least point to the two of
you Sam is Benedict and Pippa is
beatric something once happened between
them and they were almost a couple
Shakespeare never explores what that is
but we know that they have some bad
history behind them they've gone through
about two hours now in a play bantering
with each other perhaps the wittiest
banter in all of Shakespeare between man
and women and at this point in the play
they finally realize despite everything
and perhaps because of everything that
they love each other that alone would
make for a great scene but Shakespeare
is creating here two scenes that are
going going on at once one is a great
love scene in which two characters
mature characters tell each other that
they love each other the other is a
radically different scene in which a
woman asks a man to kill his best friend
only shakes bear gives you both at the
same time and I challenge even fans of
Jane Austin or Bronte or Milton to offer
something like this so with ap iies to
the actors for asking him to pick up in
the middle of an extraordinary moment
I'll get out of the
way lady
berric have you wept all this
one
yay and I will weep a while longer I
will not desire that you have no
reason I do it
freely
surely I do believe your fair cousin is
wrong how much might the man deserve of
me that would write her is there any way
to show such
friendship a very even
way but no such
friend May a man do it it is a man's
office but not
yours I do love nothing in the world so
well as
you it's not that strange
as strange as a thing I know
not it were as possible for me to
say I love nothing so well as you but
believe me not and yet I lie not I
confess nothing and yet I deny
nothing I am sorry for my cousin by my
sword beatric thou lovest me do not
swear and eat it I will swear by it that
you love me and I will make him eat it
that says I love not you will you not
eat your word with no source that can be
devised to it I pretend
I love thee why then God forgive me what
offense sweet
PC you have stayed me in a happy hour I
was about to protest I loved you and do
it with all thy
heart I love you with so much of my
heart that none is left to
protest come bid me do anything for
thee kill
claudo
huh not for the wide
world you kill me to deny it farewell
Terry sweet beatric I am gone though I
am here there is no love in you nay I
pray let me GOC in faith I will go you
be friends first you dare easier be
friends with me than fight with my enemy
is claudo thine enemy is he not approved
in the height of villain
that have slandered scorned Dishonored
my
kinswoman or that I were a man what bear
her in hand until they come to take
hands and then with public accusation
uncovered slander unmitigated ranker oh
God that I were a man I would eat his
heart in the marketplace beist talk with
a man out of the W out of a window or a
proper saying but beist sweet hero she
is wronged she has slandered she has
undone princes and counties oh sure a
princely testimony a goodly count count
convect a sweet Gallant surely oh that I
were a man for his sake or that I had
any friend that would be a man for my
sake but manhood is melted into
courtesies Valor into compliment and men
are only turned into tongue and trim
ones too he is now as Valiant as
Hercules that only tells a lie and
swears it I cannot be a man with
wishing therefore I will die a woman
with
grieving ter sweet
be by this hand I love
thee use it for my love some other way
than swearing by
it think you in your soul that the count
Claudio hath wronged
hero
yay as sure as I have a thought or a
soul
enough I am engaged I will challenge
him I kiss your hand and so I Leave
You by this hand claudo shall render me
a dear account as you hear of me so
think of me go Comfort your cousin I
must say she is
dead and so
fwell
[Applause]
it's very distracting because I'm so
caught up watching them and if you had
seen them two hours ago when they first
work through this and all of a sudden it
is more than three-dimensional it is a
multi-dimensional moment and we all got
caught up in this I I almost feel like I
couldn't should rest my case here I I
heard when Pippa said kill claudo and a
number of you laugh and it's no small
thing there are many kinds of laughter
in Shakespeare there are not many kinds
of laughter in
Milton
that